Hello everyone.
Today, we are going to look at shopping malls.
Shopping malls are very big buildings with lots of shops in them.
There are clothes shops, perfume shops, toy shops, food shops and many other types of shops.
For many people, a trip to the mall is very exciting.
There are cafes and cinemas at many malls so they're a good opportunity to meet with friends.
For people who like shopping, there are so many choices of things to buy.
All of this together can be a fun experience.
And this makes some people very happy.
However, some other people find malls noisy and crowded.
There are lots of bright lights at malls and lots of loud noises including music.
All of this can cause headaches, and for this reason, some people do not like malls.
The world's biggest shopping mall is in China.
Its name is the New South China Mall and it opened in 2005.
For some reason, this mall is not very successful and few people visited.
Perhaps this is because it is a long way from any big city.
Another very big mall is the Dubai Mall in the United Arab Emirates.
This mall is so big that it even has an aquarium inside.
There is also a theme park, an ice rink, and some hotels.
In the future, perhaps malls will get even bigger.
Who knows, maybe one day, there will be a mall the size of a city.
That brings us to the end of today's talk.
I hope you enjoyed it and look forward to seeing you all next time.
Goodbye.